a number of past Kennedy Center honorees
have certainly been movie stars in that
classic sense actors with class and
sophistication Cary Grant and Henry
Fonda and then I think of George a man
who once defecated in Richard kyne's
kitty litter box as a joke
[Applause]
oh Bill Clinton's stationary and wrote
fake notes to actors saying how much the
president loved their movies
and George I know
but let's be honest it takes a village
to style a star into being People
magazine sexiest man alive I've been
there those experts can transform anyone
even this guy there he is
[Applause]
yeah I'm all so that's George Clooney
that is
the sexiest man alive and you married
him